[Music]
you have already experienced the
pressure of having to bring a beloved
book character to life from the silver
screen how would you compare that
experience of pressure with having to
bring a beloved animated character to
life I think I started playing Hermione
when I was a child myself and so there
was kind of an ignorance is bliss factor
a little bit now I was an adult but I
knew I was bringing to life a sacred
part of people's childhoods that's when
the last pack and fall people really
loved the original so remaking that is
like I think probably this time round I
felt it more um
having said that getting to do all the
singing dancing comedic aspect of it I
think kept the experience pretty light
you could you basically can't take
yourself too seriously when you're
dancing with a man in a muscle suit on a
muscle suit on stilts you talking to a
dancing candlestick you've got to have a
sense of humor about it all
speaking of Harry Potter a lot of the
fans want to know are you and Daniel
still and touched you guys text isn't
said anything about the film um gosh we
actually have a group whatsapp which I
invited everyone really from the main
cast from Harry Potter to come to the
screenings and uh Matt Lewis and tom
Felton came to screening we just had in
LA it's kind of like Pokemon I'm trying
to catch them all right now I've got a
Barney and Dan left you know we are all
spread all over the globe and so you
know it's a case of trying to like get
people into the right places but and
bring up February um supported by my by
my old co-stars
[Music]
you